if you want to better understand
yourself and how to better interact with
others you need to understand your
values that's why the minimalist created
a free downloadable and printable values
worksheet that will help you identify
all of your different values and the
obstacles that are in your way head on
over to the minimalists comm /v to
download your free values worksheet
today enjoy
JC says what do at jfm and at Ryan
Nicodemus fear nothing we were careless
at leader wise in there as well so I had
a very irrational fear for a long time
and I think it actually maybe helped me
start writing in a weird way so there's
like a perverse benefit from this but I
had a fear of being forgotten and now
when you pan out long enough I am
guaranteed to be forgotten and so even
if our books do incredibly well and they
affect multiple generations for to come
even after my death on a long enough
timeline I'm gonna be forgotten maybe
it's a hundred years from now I was
talking to podcast Sean about this the
other day yeah I'll be lucky to be a
footnote in history books a thousand
years from now right that's I mean such
a long time but you pan out ten thousand
years a hundred thousand years which is
still just a blip an earth time and the
universe for sure a hundred thousand
years nothing no one will remember who
we were and I can either continue to
fear that irrationally or I can accept
it and say wow no one's gonna remember
who I am
but that means I should at least make
this moment count because those moments
a hundred thousand years from now aren't
going to matter to me at all
yeah what are you scared of man giraffes
it's a rational fear clowns I think for
me what I mean it's such a what
something I fear the most is make I
think I've
you're making the wrong decision yeah I
think that's probably like my biggest
fear on a daily basis look I like I said
though I think I have a great support
team from you know my wife John who I
love my dog
I mean honestly down to like my my
friends my my manager my my family there
are people that I have as a support
system but for me I tend to kind of have
this you know my successes are my own
and my failures are my own and I think
making the wrong decision is is probably
what on a day-to-day basis would be the
thing that I probably am fearing the
most I have a fear of not making a
decision I'm look very different in fact
it's almost to my detriment I'm a very
decisive person they oughta just make
the decision get it out of the way sort
of thing rip the band-aid off so to
speak and and sometimes that's really
helpful because it's like alright that's
done making at least make a decision you
end up making the wrong decision unless
you made a decision you can correct that
later but I have a fear of not making a
decision where if and it helps me not
procrastinate in a way but but it also
it also means I don't always sit and
make necessarily the best decision right
I would say that the outcome is the same
worrying about now I want to make a
decision and like we're like I think the
reason I it's not so much a fear it's
just it's so much of you know with what
I do and I mean I think most people day
to day it's it's just going through
those motions of I think I think just
for me I guess it's it's like I over
thinking things sometimes you know to
like to to degree where it's like not
unhealthy but you're you know sometimes
I think that to me is what like is it it
gets me the most anxious and I think
maybe I'm using the word fear where I
should be using the word anxious I think
I get the most anxious one you know I'm
I don't know exactly like worrying about
making the right wrong
versus just making the decision and I
think I can I tend to overthink that
sometimes round about you oh you know
it's funny I talk I was talking earlier
about you shouldn't care what people
think about you but I do care what
people think it's about how I manage
that fear though but I'll tell you the
one thing that there's - like - the
biggest fears about what people think
about me one if people think I've
disrespected them like I don't know why
but like I will think to myself
sometimes like oh that person took me
the wrong way
thought I disrespected them and that'll
like eat me up and I have to go yeah
fear be misunderstood or fear of like
someone looking at me like I'm an idiot
and that's mainly because I feel like an
idiot a lot of times but I don't want
people to know that
you